seven Democratic presidential rivals
will debate tonight in New Hampshire
before its first in the nation primary
two new polls show Bernie Sanders and P
Budaj edge fighting for the two top
spots Iowa's Democratic Party says all
precincts in that state are now
reporting results from Monday's caucus
and those results show that Budaj and
Sanders are in a virtual tie among state
delegates Jane Sanders the senator's
wife spoke with the circus co-host Alex
Wagner about Budaj edge declaring
victory before all the Iowa numbers were
released what was your feeling when
mayor Pete went out there and said
basically I'm the victor did we've
emerged victorious I think candidates do
what they have to do yeah in order to
move on I mean he needed he needed that
yeah to move on and the fact is they
both have a good night and and others
did not but we're confident that Bernie
will end up Victor and Alex Wagner is
also a CBS News special correspondent
and she joins us from Manchester New
Hampshire Alex good morning good morning
guys so we have this new polling it
shows Budaj and Sanders frontrunner if
not favorites what does that mean to the
rest of the field it means that they are
in the fight of their political lives
and I think you're seeing that reflected
in some of the rhetoric coming from the
Biden campaign the Warren campaign knows
that they need to do well here and it
reflects fundamentally two realities
Tony the first is you know up until this
point this has very much been a jump
ball Democratic voters were shopping
around they weren't sure who they wanted
to support this was anyone's race after
Iowa it is a different story and it
reflects the second truth which is that
Democratic voters also want to coalesce
behind someone they see the president
amassing a war chest they see him with
all time approval ratings highs they see
the Republican Party consolidated around
this president and they know he is going
to be a formidable adversary in 2020 and
therefore they want to find their
nominee and they want to get behind him
or her so we've got Elizabeth Warren in
third place in these new polls you might
think she would do well there she's from
nearby Massachusetts where she's a
senator but I happen to know that some
voters in New Hampshire called
Massachusetts tax atchoo sits and all of
her policies involved raising taxes so
right now in this camp
this primary is New Hampshire make or
break for Elizabeth Warren yeah and I
definitely think it is I was with the
senator last night at an event and I
asked her I said look you came in third
in Iowa is there nothing your campaign
wants to do differently in the state of
New Hampshire I mean especially given
the stakes at hand and you know the
Warren campaign is resolutely on message
and she said look I'm not employing
fancy political consultants I'm out here
fighting the same fight I've been
fighting my entire life it is clear that
she believes her message about big
structural change is the thing that is
gonna stand her in good stead with
Democratic voters and she is sticking to
that message is a very different
approach than Joe Biden well speaking of
Biden Alex his campaign had a big summit
yesterday he called it a guy Oh a gut
punch for him he's running a distant
fourth in this poll what are the stakes
for Biden here now huge I mean this is
someone who was for a while a presumed
frontrunner and to come in fourth in
Iowa and to have high stakes in New
Hampshire Joe Biden is laying it out on
all on the field and he is being in
quintessential sort of Biden overshare
is saying look I need this if you guys
don't come out for me my candidacy could
be over there's a lot of hyperbole in
American politics but in the case of Joe
Biden if he comes out here with a third
or fourth place finish I think it is
spells real trouble for his campaign not
just in terms of support but also
dollars I mean Joe Biden has limited
funds left in his war chest and he needs
the donor class to be convinced that he
has staying power and Alex president
Trump is claiming victory after being
acquitted do the Democrats need to turn
the page when it comes to impeachment
Jericka let me tell you one thing about
the senator the three senators that had
to jet back to Washington DC for the
impeachment trial senators clip I should
say for Senator Bennet Chlo bashar
warren and sanders they do not talk
about zalenski or Biden or Ukraine on
the campaign trail because they
understand a fundamental truth about
where the Democratic electorate is about
this is not about impeachment that is
not what is going to win this race for
Democrats this is about health insurance
the social safety net climate change gun
safety reform Ukraine does not figure
into all of this now Democratic members
of Congress have a different strategy
and how the demo
to party reconciles the national stage
with the washington stage is anyone's
guess coming into the fall of 2020 very
unique state New Hampshire also very
independent only state in the Union
where there is no law requiring adults
to wear its seat belts but Alex we
expect you to buckle up and be safe and
I will see you always I will see you on
Monday when I'll be out there as well
the circus by the way folks airs Sunday
on Showtime a division of Viacom CBS you
can check your local listings